[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره افادت وسائل الاعلام
الفلسطينيه بان قواتين من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت بلده قباطيه جنوب جنين
في الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم واشتبكت مع
مسلحين واعتقلت عددا من الفلسطينيين وقالت
فصائل مقاومه فلسطينيه ان مقاتليها خاضوا
اشتباكات مع القوات الاحتلال في البلده
وهذه مشاهدينا صورا وردتنا قبل قليل من
هناك
قبل المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من التطورات
الجاريه في اسرائيل وفي لقاء خاص مع
الجزيره دعا رايدر القاده الاسرائيليين
للتوصل لتسويه تستعيد الهدوء
هذا وفدى ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان رئيس الوزرايه وعزاء لاعضاء حكومته
بعدم التعقيب على تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن بشان التعديلات القضائيه وبعد ان
اعلن رفضه للضغوط الامريكيه على حكومته
قال نتنياهو ان التحالف بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل لا يتزعزع رغم وجود
خلافات عرضيه بينهما
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
الاستراتيجيه صاروخيه بدات تدريبات تشمل
انظمه صواريخ يارس النوويه الباليستيه
العابره للقارات بمشاركه ثلاثه الاف جندي
في غضون ذلك تجري واشنطن
مناورات استعدادا لاي هجوم قد يستهدف شبه
الجزيره الكوريه
قال الكرملين النصراع مع الغرب هو حرب
بالمعنى الاوسع الى الكلمه وسيستمر لفتره
طويله من جهته اكد رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه خلال جلسه في الكونغرس
لانه من الصعب للغايه خوض حرب مع روسيا
والصين بشكل متزامن
القوات المسلحه الروسيه تسلمت المئات من
دبابات في 90 بالاضافه الى دبابات 72
بثلاثه ام الحديثه للغايه وذلك لاستخدامها
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
شارك اكثر من 1700 عسكري في مناورات
عسكريه بقاعده امريكيه في جنوب المانيا
وشارك في هذه المناورات عسكريون من 18
بلدا وتزامنت مع مناورات في استونيا
قال نطق باسم الجيش السوداني ان القوات
المسلحه ملتزمه بالعمليه السياسيه وكانت
الجلسه الختاميه لورشه الاصلاح العسكري
والامني عقدت في الخرطومه في غياب رئيس
مجلس السياده النائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وممثلي الجيش وعاشرت مصادر عسكريه سودانيه
للجزيره الا ان الجيش غير راضي عن الورقه
التي قدمها ممثل القوات الدعم السريع
لكونها لم تتناول خطوه دمج الدعم السريع
داخل الجيش وكان نائب رئيس المجلس السياده
الاصلاح لابد ان يشمل مؤسسات الدوله كافه
اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]